well U.S President Joe Biden has denied
the United States or NATO played any
role in the Wagner Mutiny calling it a
struggle within the Russian system
Rosalind Jordan reports now from
Washington D.C
members of the Biden Administration
spent all of the weekend here in
Washington and for the president at Camp
David Consulting with allies and
partners about the situation inside
Russia there was a message being
communicated over the weekend that the
U.S was not going to try to predict how
the crisis would be resolved but on
Monday before the president gave some
comments on an unrelated matter he took
the opportunity to stress very publicly
the US's position on what was happening
between Evgeni pregozian and his Wagner
group and the administration of
President Vladimir Putin this is the U.S
President Joe Biden
we made clear that we were not involved
we had nothing to do with it this was
part of a struggle within the Russian
system
I also talked to the length of President
zielinski of Ukraine will be keeping in
contact with him and maybe picking them
later today early tomorrow morning to
make sure we continue to remain on the
same page
I told them that no matter what happened
in Russia
let me say it again no matter what
happened in Russia we the United States
would continue to support Ukraine's
defense and its sovereignty and its
territorial Integrity now given that the
Biden Administration has been imposing
sanctions after sanctions against Russia
because of its invasion of Ukraine one
might assume and certainly there were
some pundits here in the U.S suggesting
this that the U.S might be anticipating
with Glee a deposing of Vladimir Putin
and a replacement with someone else in
charge at the Kremlin however there was
an effort on Monday to reiterate that as
far as the U.S is concerned this is not
happening this is John Kirby a
spokesperson for the National Security
Council we believe it's up to the
Russian people to determine who their
leadership is and we would prefer to see
uh
uh Russia not invade their neighboring
countries we would prefer to see Russia
since they already did that remove all
their troops from Ukraine and end the
war today which they could do that's
what we prefer the other point that
members of the Biden Administration
wanted to underscore throughout the
entire weekend and into Monday is that
as far as it's concerned there has not
been any change to Russia's nuclear
weapons posture this is of course a real
concern because the U.S and Russia have
a number of Arms Control agreements
which govern how and when they would
ever use nuclear weapons but the U.S is
saying at least for the time being it is
reassured that there isn't any threat of
any sort of nuclear missile launch from
the Russian side
Rosalind Jordan Al Jazeera Washington